all right it looks like we're now live
for the uh birthday bash
and i'm happy to see uh people here
already dominic
uh says i wish you happy birthday hope
you're doing well funny thing it's my
birthday too so happy birthday to you
dominic i'm now in my second week of
reading being in time it's difficult but
i
like the challenge so that's that's
awesome yeah being in time is gonna take
you a while and it's it's something that
you're going to have to read and reread
like most philosophical
classics harold covley a good friend of
mine over in norway has donated to urban
cat coalition which is a local
organization here that uh does a lot of
great work
homing
feral and abandoned and
sheltered cats in different places
arranging adoptions fostering
stuff like that getting them off the
streets so to speak
so
i don't really have a huge plan
for this session other than to say
you know maybe i'll talk a little bit
about
aging and you know a few things i've
learned along the way and birthdays and
stuff like that
um i have a cousin actually whose
birthday it is as well
julia who's a good bit younger than me
she's got the same birthday and we were
looking up famous birthdays and of
course there's like tons and tons of
people who uh have
any day you pick are gonna have your
birthday but a year older than me is
christian slater and edward norton and
so my wife was remarking at breakfast
that it's a you know bad boys birthday
club of sorts so
all right um so people are are wishing
happy birthdays bruce nashant and alex
thanks uh very much for that and
i'll talk a little bit about what's
going on the rest of the day
uh because some of you may find that
interesting
um so you know dinner tonight is at the
calderon club uh an italian place where
we went last year just down the block
from us here in milwaukee and i had
spaghetti and meatballs which was you
know my favorite uh dish as a child and
i still like quite a bit today last time
but i might i might have something
different
uh this time around and before that we
are going to the sip and purr cat cafe
some of you may remember from social
media
that uh when we were in green bay
ironically not for a football game but a
soccer game earlier this summer
my wife andy and i stopped in at um
this i forget exactly what the name was
but it was a cat shelter and
you could go in and um hang out and they
had all these you know cats who most of
whom were special needs like you know
who had been like hit by cars or birth
defects or things like that or who were
it was sort of a cat hospice as well um
i i actually spent about an hour with a
uh an older cat uh who was dying of
cancer and just sat with her in my lap
her name was agnes
and so we're we're going to this cat
cafe and it's not quite so hospice
oriented they have kittens and they have
other cats up for adoption and you have
to reserve a time
and go in for about an hour and you get
to hang out with the cats which is kind
of nice for me
particularly since you know we lost
sassy earlier this year um i do love
cats and dogs and other animals and so
getting to spend some time with them and
you know make a little donation is a
nice thing
um all right so let's see i'm also going
to be doing some some work on my
marquette classes which i'll tell you
about in a minute let me
look at the comments again so drewer
says speaking of recurring dates and
time circles you should look into
astrology yeah i'm not into astrology
had plenty of time in my life to look
into that
you know and i
goes back to ancient times and ancient
philosophers uh talk about why it's it's
actually wrong themselves including
everyone from aristotle to augustine
um
bruno says i always think italian is
great
yeah you know it depends on the place
right massacre says happy birthday i
appreciate you because you taught me to
be more critical less committed to any
philosophy and have a less reductive
worldview happy birthday thanks yeah
actually i was talking with a
friend and client earlier today a guy
who's about my age in in london who had
a very different you know
life and and has gotten into philosophy
and he was asking me
um so you know you're you're not
committed to any one particular
philosopher how do you handle having
these like competing voices in your head
and i said well most of the time they're
pretty quiet you know it's sort of like
having a hallway that you're living in
in a common house and each person's got
their own room if you go knock on their
door maybe they'll come out sometimes
they're wandering the halls and you know
jabbering about this or that but most of
the time you can kind of pick and choose
which one you want
uh oh good mark smith's here a good
friend of mine says hope you've had a
great birthday want to donate but seems
it's not set up for here
thanks for doing the fundraiser have a
beer for me
later yeah i suppose i probably didn't
set up things properly in terms of
monetization or something drewer says
cat equals euphemism no cats are just
cats just like you know sometimes a
cigar is just a cigar as um
freud observed right
um only in space says happy birthday to
our stoic youtube dad well i'm not
really a stoic you know uh
stoicism is just one of the philosophies
that i draw on rather eclectically
patricia says hope you've had a great
birthday thanks for everything you do
cannot thank you enough for getting me
started on plato hegel and stoicism
that's that's that's awesome yeah
there's there's so many great things
in philosophy out there and since we
have a little pause in the comments i'll
say another thing by the way again i
don't have any structure for this it's
going to be just kind of rambling and
you know
picking up whatever people want to put
down and and and going with it but
you know thinking to
like
who should we cover in in philosophy
right this is a perennial
issue especially for like introductory
classes so i'm i'm teaching an
effectively an intro class it's called
foundations of philosophy but it's
really an intro class
i'm teaching that um
this
semester at marquette university and you
always have to like figure out okay who
are we actually going to
cover
and there's so many interesting thinkers
and texts and topics that you can only
do like a little little tiny bit
and you can try to do it by being very
representative but that never really
works or you can
pick a particular emphasis for that
class i usually
choose three main themes um that i
orient everything around one is human
nature
another is the you know the virtues and
the vices and you know you could call it
human anthropology parts of the soul and
then the third thing is usually like
free will and determinism and choice and
where that fits into that
and so
you know we look at some plato some
aristotle some cicero there's a little
bit of lucretius in there
um some anselm some augustine some
aquinas some descartes some hob some
hume some mary wollstonecraft
uh we finish up with with uh sart and
deboir and you think about that it
sounds like a pretty good class but it's
like looking at a spectrum
of of light and only getting a little
bit of this and this and this and this
which is kind of a
it's always kind of a downer and i can
say the same thing about my video
production right people are like oh wow
you got so many videos covering like
everybody and and my my response is
usually
it's not covering everybody by by any
means and there's so many huge gaps that
i would like to fill in and maybe i will
over the next
10 years but even with that there's
still going to be massive massive
gaps so all right harold says happy
birthday uh this is also the birthday of
antonio solari and the death day of
genghis khan
um well that's that's quite something
you know
uh alex says putnam i'm not sure what
that means
casual philosophy what do you think is
philosophically interesting about metal
as a musical genre oh all sorts of
things i mean that's why
uh scott tarrouli and i have been doing
that classic metal class where we we
bring in all sorts of philosophy related
things we've been doing that now for i
think close to two years
and
maybe even a little bit longer i'm not
not quite sure i'd have to look in the
the videos when we actually
started it
and um
yeah uh
you know there's there's all sorts of
things where you can say there's like
applications of
philosophical issues to the world of
heavy metal
and they would apply also to other other
genres as well like for instance
when does a band cease being the same
band if it has only one original member
in it and that one original member is
kind of a marginal person
can it call itself the same band or not
well that that's a metaphysical question
right or
we another one that we picked was what
makes best albums the best and so that's
a question of value right which is also
quite quite interesting
as well and then you can ask about like
are genres real you know do they did
they designate something that is a hard
distinction
or or not you know um and there's you
know interesting
things about
you look at like the background of some
of these um great metal artists uh where
there's a lot of reflection on on what's
going on like ronnie james dio i think
all of you know i'm a huge fan of
randy james view and i consider him to
be probably the smartest person ever in
the field of heavy metal
and that's saying a lot because there's
some pretty brilliant thinkers in there
very reflective people
so i mean those are some some
connections i would say
um
mark has a question for me since you
call yourself a cicerone eclectic
i'm wondering what you would think of
somebody calling themselves a sadlerian
eclectic what would that mean to you i
mean i think that it probably it's one
of those things where cicero's pretty
famous
and if you say to somebody i'm a
cicerone and eclectic they might not
know what that means but at least
they'll have somebody to associate that
with if you call yourself a sadlerian
eclectic i think nobody's gonna know
what you're talking about
and and
since i am a ciceronian eclectic
ciceronian style eclectic it would be
kind of
redundant to have an extra
term in there i think right um
a lot of people saying happy birthday um
[Music]
thanks for for that and
uh michael gonzalez says my birthday is
tomorrow so happy birthday in advance to
you
um
[Music]
even says glad for all your videos happy
to help contribute to a good cause the
urban cat coalition
as i was mentioning at the top of the
hour they do a lot of great work they
are a
um
they don't have an actual physical
location they coordinate
cats who have been you know
um
feral or abandoned or
uh are in tough circumstances
they coordinate fostering and adoption
efforts and also you know um
send um
litter and food and toys and all these
sorts of things to the places they they
need to go so it's a it's a great
organization here in the milwaukee area
um
albert says live long and prosper let me
see if i can do the there we go yes live
and prosper got the vulcan salute uh
mark says i like the discussion on
rebellion as a theme this is referencing
the classic metal class had some
nostalgic value also made me appreciate
how much has remained constant in my
character over
the years
powwow says certainly good metal bands
touch on existential philosophy at the
gates recent albums
yeah i should mention too when it comes
to metal i'm not listening to all that
much
recent or contemporary stuff and i i
don't do much in the
uh the genres that have really taken a
lot like death and and
black metal or you know these very niche
things where it's like
scandinavian black pirate metal or
things like like that um i do like uh
power metal and doom metal but i don't i
don't like seek out new bands all that
much it's enough just to like go back
into the 70s and 80s for me
and find a lot of the bands and things
you know the albums that i missed in
that time because you know we live in
this incredible
era of the internet
where
you know growing up here in in wisconsin
you wouldn't hear about a lot of the
bands that were around until they made
it big and then they were in the record
stores or they're being played on the
radio or you'd read about them in circus
magazine right and so quite a few of
these
you know i'm discovering in well from
like 2010 onward
and so that that's kind of kind of cool
um all right a lot a lot of questions
people are are bringing up um
[Music]
dominic any thoughts on anarchism
bakunin or kropotkin
not really um it's been a long long time
since i've read any uh of that
literature and it's not really something
that i i work in
um world to win just pop by to say hello
voice my appreciation for the philosophy
education you put out into the world
um yeah thanks yeah i like uh i mean i
like what i do that was one of the
things i was gonna do is reflect a
little bit on
my
life so far i've been pretty fortunate
um
some of you may have seen you know
recently i put out a uh
another twitter video
where we're looking at
the role that luck
in many different levels plays in
academic hiring and jobs
and man does it it play a huge role and
i've been pretty fortunate i haven't
been fortunate in the sense of like you
know getting the plum job i mean the
only time i was on the tenure track was
for three years at fayetteville state
university um but i've been pretty lucky
in my in my career overall that you know
i was started producing videos when
youtube was
taking off and i reached you know a
sizable
audience that i i'm still you know
reaching today because there's this
hunger out there for
you know substantive engagement with
philosophical ideas that just isn't
being met by the the um
you know the culture and by academic
institutions
and you know i've been lucky that i've
been able to teach in academic
institutions
now for 22 23 years
i get more
sometimes more class requests than i can
actually fill
and uh
you know i mean look at what's behind me
all these these great books
uh this is this is my wealth right this
is where a lot of our our money is tied
up in those in the bookshelves you know
um and uh i'm you know i'm happy with
that um i could i could spend the rest
of my life
working on
this this stuff and probably never have
to retire
so
yeah
um
batu what's your take on moral realism
versus anti-realism i'm not i'm not
really an ism person so i don't really
worry too much about those
kinds of debates and disputes
uh albert have you ever thought about
dressing like greeks did in ancient
times i mean not as like something i
would do
day to day
really even for special occasions
but um i did think about doing some
stuff very early on with youtube
that would be like socratic dialogues
and this is back when i was at
fayetteville state university and i had
a colleague richard hall who was an
older guy
british had done some acting so you know
a lot a lot of stage presence and i
thought he could be socrates
and i could be like mino or ion or you
know some other some other guy and i'd
you know let my hair down and we'd wear
togas and sit around and and film it
actually my colleague michelle carpenter
was saying she might be willing to get
in on it and then i left you know so so
that never came to fruition but i i
thought that would be kind of a cool
thing you know
all right uh world to win uh periphery
has some really intense poetic and
philosophical lyrics on top of
incredible musicianship not sure if
they'd be my taste but give them a try
yeah maybe maybe i will i got so many
other bands to to listen to
already it's hard
it's hard to stay on top of things right
and even the classic bands are like
putting out new albums
once scott and i resume classic metal
class we're going to do another review
session
where we're just going to be looking at
new wave of british heavy metal bands
that have put out new albums within the
last couple years like rock goddess and
raven
and
oh you know tiger's a pain tang has a
great new album so it's hard to stay on
top of all of this
um
[Music]
malcolm has a good question here best
birthday memory so
i would say
um one of the ones that really sticks
with me
i was six years old and you know we
moved into this
house out in the countryside
in a subdivision which took a while to
actually develop and i want to say the
house was built like in 74
and maybe we moved in in 74 or early 75
and uh so you know for my sixth birthday
in 1976 which which wasn't like a big
year that was the year of the the set
the
bicentennial so you know around 4th of
july i remember like riding my big wheel
in a parade in the town of delafield or
maybe it was maybe it was the village of
wales that we lived close by to
in any case a couple things happened on
my birthday
um that year
the first thing was that a stray cat
that my grandfather had brought from
chicago
and let loose in our our yard and then
she went into the woods behind our place
um she um
came into the garage
and had kittens in the morning and we
went out there and we hear all this like
you know mewing sounds and sure enough
she's there with like five kittens in uh
a kiddie pool you know
um where she'd chosen to go and my you
know my mom was like don't touch them
you know they're blind they can't do
anything but of course you know it
didn't take long before we're picking
them up and and holding them and looking
at them and all that they all went out
to in to northwestern indiana
to my grandfather and grandmother's
place
and and lived for a while out there and
they didn't last you know super super
long because they were all outside cats
so that was one thing
and then um
my mom had put together a birthday party
and it was like all the neighborhood
kids you know
and one of the neighborhood kids who was
considerably older he was in high school
um one of the schmidt boys and i don't
remember the name of him i hung out with
steve schmidt some of the time and the
the sister would sometimes babysit us
but this is like the older one so he was
probably like a senior in high school
he did magic like he did magic shows and
stuff like that and so
he put on a magic show
and the thing that i remember is he did
a trick with a cake right you know where
you like crack the eggs into your hat
and
all this kind of stuff and then boom you
know here's the the cake and the cake
wasn't particularly good and my mom was
like well that's because he left the
eggshells in there you know so those are
some interesting birthday memories i
mean i've had so many i suppose right
all right um
travis burke thoughts on irregina
interesting guy you know important in
the
the history of medieval philosophy and
neoplatonism
you know that's that's about it uh
drewer ever dug into this nick land and
ccru hyperstation stuff
um yeah i've actually got lands uh
fang numina i was on a
a
podcast about that about a year ago or
so
um
my take is that nick land is very
overrated
and
is basically just doing the kind of
stuff that we did in continental
philosophy in the 80s and 90s and early
2000s and
you know there's nothing particularly
remarkable about it
he's not terrible he's not
you know great
and then he went off the deep end you
know i guess he fancied himself uh a
real auteur
and um you know got into the dark
enlightenment stuff and and the dark
enlightenment stuff i mean i started
reading that stuff back in the early
2000s when menses mold bug was kind of
becoming a big thing and you could see
even then that it wasn't like something
radically new it was a regurgitation of
you know charlemagne you know
traditionalism in other respects just
updated for the internet age and um so i
you know
land is okay he's he's not terrible he's
not great um
that's what i would say
um
all right let's see what do we got here
just skipped a little bit
mark says a cheesy question but
worthwhile
what would you say if you go back to
your 20 year old self
speculate about what your 70 year old
self would have to say about you now
i mean i don't know what the 70 year old
self would have to say
um i imagine he'll be in a similar
trajectory to what i'm doing today you
know maybe
still producing videos i mean who knows
what youtube is going to look like 20
years from now though right
um
but 20 year old self um
i mean i was i was entering college
uh having been in the army having worked
in restaurants
i would say
you know there's a lot of things that i
thought were like
really
important back then that i was mixed up
about and i was pretty rigid
in in a lot of ways that i'm not so much
today so maybe i would say i don't know
from the vantage point of the future a
lot of the things that you consider to
be absolutely important probably are
less important than you think so and you
shouldn't get too too worked up about
them you know
um
nissan says apart from philosophy would
have been your view on poetry as an
alternative way to look at life
wordsworth fan here
i don't actually get that much out of
poetry i have to i have to admit you
know when i'm reading it um
there's only certain authors that i kind
of connect with like uh rainer maria
rilke and i probably get more out of
relka's
letters than i do out of some of his
poetry although his stuff is pretty
great
i i tend to like the ones where there is
some meat to it right so wordsworth is a
good example of that i mean
shakespeare's sonnets are another good
example john dunn you know
um
i'll actually tell you an interesting
story with respect to poetry so i i used
to
sit in on when i was a an undergraduate
in college on these poetry classes in
part because uh
some of my friends were going to them
and in part because this uh woman that i
was dating was also a writing major at
the time
and carl elder was um
he was a cool guy
and
he was also quite critical like people
would try stuff in the poetry class and
be like that's too didactic you know
what are you trying to prove to people
you know and so he was kind of a harsh
critic
and he liked the stuff that i was
bringing to class i would write sonnets
and things like that
and i went into his office
one time and i said you know i'm
thinking about um
dropping the philosophy major and
changing to writing
and he said oh that's a terrible idea
and i said well why because you know
he's like
denigrating his own
craft and he said well you know all
these kids come in here and they just
want to write about things and a lot of
their writing is is kind of meta it's
writing about how hard it is to write
and stuff like that stick with a field
where you're actually like studying
something because then you'll have
something to write about it won't be all
this boring crap that they're writing
you know i was like well okay that cause
that makes sense you know so you can
always be a writer you know but don't
study writing you know and i thought oh
that's kind of a cool idea so that
that's what i ended up doing andy uh
good to see you uh happy birthday greg
we need to chat soon uh andy by the way
is uh
working on his masters um which is great
to to see
um
he and i have corresponded a couple
times well actually a number of times
about uh different philosophers and uh
uh i was talking with somebody earlier
today about this i think a lot of people
wind up coming to me in part
because in academic philosophy
so many
professors and programs give the
students so little helpful guidance you
know about like well how should you work
on this or what should you study or
things like that so
all right uh
harold says what do you think about the
superior warf hypothesis that our
perception of the world is affected by
the language that we speak if you've got
the the weak version of it
framed like that then i think yes when
it when it's extended into
the strong version which says that we're
basically like isolated in our own
little linguistic worlds i don't really
buy that because um you know it's not as
if every language is its own sphere of
incommensurability with other languages
the fact that we can translate between
them
you know certainly
uh
means something so
casual philosophy sadler react series
incoming um
[Music]
yeah i don't know i don't know about uh
that reacts to what like you mean like
reaction videos where i'm
listening to somebody
playing something and then i like ham it
up for the camera i'm like oh
wow this is such amazing music holy crap
you know
i don't think i'll ever do things like
that because those those strike me as um
a lot of them are kind of
ungenuine
you know
um or you know uh
watching something gross or watching
something yeah i don't know that that
that i'll do those i mean i got so much
other stuff to uh
to do right
albert says thanks for reading my rants
although all countries have philosophy
and their culture
i always default to ancient greece
yeah i mean there's there's philosophy
going on
in all sorts of places um
so only in space best birthday gift to
well that's nice too
bruno have you ever imagined plato's
republic transformed into a play okay so
going back to the dialogues thing
the challenge with these sorts of things
is that
there's very little action taking place
right and so to
to turn
platonic dialogues into plays especially
longer platonic dialogues
where there's not an awful lot of action
happening
i think it's kind of tough because you
need to be able to hold your audience's
attention right
so
i mean
even like hume's dialogues concerning
natural religion would suffer from from
a similar
problem
you'd need to like jazz it up somehow
you know
now with the republic
you do have
you do have the opportunity to like as
socrates is talking about the city
you know this imaginary city
you could like have um scenes like where
he's talking about the education right
you have like a a little scene
or the allegory of the cave of course
there's there's dramatizations of that
as well
or the you know the myth of the
afterlife towards the end
um
but that would be tough to pull off
actually that would be that would be
kind of a cool thing to attempt
um but i don't know who would actually
take it on i would hope that they would
stick close to the text
and
um
you know
have uh
a consultant who's a philosopher on it
that would be that would be kind of good
um but yeah that would be that'd be kind
of neat to see i think
um
got a lot of messages here so absalom
how important is philosophy as a tool
for improving mental health
is it a useful aid for an overall
population or just on an individual
basis um i would say you know both and
everything in between but it depends on
what kind of philosophy you're
talking about you know are we talking
about having people read contemporary
pieces and analytic philosophy very
narrowly focused that's probably not
going to do an awful lot of
good other than fostering the capacity
to like make distinctions and
breakdown arguments um if we're talking
about you know studying stoicism or
you know aristotelian ethics okay maybe
that might have some more direct
application to a person's life
you know or two to a population right
uh muhammad says happy birthday
professor hope you have a wonderful day
i'm sure you know birthdays weren't as
well recorded in history
than dates of death however you
approached ideas and even your own death
i mean i don't really think about my own
death that much i really need to start
getting my my butt in gear
and like get a will and that will has to
include
um
my digital presence as well you know i
probably need something like a literary
executor except for all these videos and
podcasts and stuff like that
um
you know i mean i've grown up with death
like a good friend of mine who i think
is here bruce um
that heideggerian being towards death
i've always had that i've always known
that people can die including myself
and that existence is is uh precarious
since i was a kid
um
and you know i've had a lot of people in
my life
pass away so i'm kind of
prepared for it i mean i'd like to live
as long as i can
because you know i want to be with the
people i love and accomplish things that
i think are worth doing
but if i had to die tomorrow i i
wouldn't say that i've missed out on too
much in life and you know i'd want to
provide for the people that are
important for me my my wife my kids
some of my friends perhaps could get
some of these books you know
although coordinating that would be kind
of kind of difficult
max max says hi from ukraine happy
birthday love your content thanks
um
and we got some more birthday wishes
from drewer robert
albert says thanks for reading oh we
already already looked at that one it
looks like maybe that's a repeat
uh do you see trevitaviani experience
with pataphysics nope i don't have any
experience with that
uh ben duvall what are your thoughts on
the great reset plan of the
wef frankfurt school neo-marxist
influences on western culture i think
that's
silliness there there isn't a
frankfurt neo-marxist influence on
western culture
when you actually start looking into
things and you get away from like silly
right-wing blogs and books and videos
um
i mean it'd be a better thing if there
was actually some some real influence
of that um
casual philosophy when you see a band
and a significant number them are music
grads you know it'll be technically good
but boring
um i wouldn't say that at all i mean
you know a good person to to kick that
over too would be scott taruli
who uh teaches at the berkeley school of
music and
has a number of former students in you
know metal bands out there and they're
they're quite good uh andromeda thoughts
on dave david foster wallace i've only
read a little bit of his stuff didn't
find it very interesting i think he's
kind of over uh overrated and
just not you know
uh not interested in him
um
well this is interesting rhino horn it
was pretty awesome when you showed up
for university of wisconsin-eau claire
so that was years ago when i first got
here to wisconsin
that would have been for the wisconsin
philosophy society when the university
of eau claire was hosting it so we must
have met then so that's that's kind of
cool
uh powwow agreed on superior warf what
if a person grew up speaking five
languages it does affect some aspects of
life but not the entire perception
yeah the superior warf hypothesis um
like conjectures don't take into account
um multilingualism you know which can be
like you grew up speaking them it could
be you studied them
there's all different ways of knowing a
language and using a language so i think
sometimes we got to be you know we got
to get into the distinctions to talk
about that
ken black well somebody who comes and
contributes quite a bit to the heavy
metal classes says happy birthday to you
thanks ken always good to see you
um
ksbf and twilighty the idols nietzsche
said at 31 is but a child you're a
strapping man now happy birthday thank
you for your output
yeah i mean nietzsche he says a lot of
things doesn't he i wouldn't necessarily
take them all to to i wouldn't believe
all the things that he says necessarily
but
as aristotle remarks uh some people are
immature in their years and other people
are immature in their minds so you could
be 52 and still be pretty pretty
childish in many respects
uh keaton happy birthday thanks for
helping me understand philosophy i'm
reading st john of the cross his poetry
now any thoughts or tips i've never read
his his poetry
um the only thing that i've read by him
is um the stuff that pertains to the
seven deadly sins
um i'm not a big fan of mystics in
general and uh so he's not somebody i've
actually spent enough time on to say
much about
gaia are you
at all interested in the george r martin
targaryen prequel series coming to tv
soon interestingly enough my wife and i
were just discussing that last night
um
i'm not interested in it at all and we
watched the preview for it and i was
like oh great more more attractive
people put into
you know stunning backdrops saying
dramatic things
it's just it's not something
that i want to see
put on tv for me i mean i what i would
love to see is george r martin finished
the last two books
and who knows if that's going to happen
or not but
i don't have high hopes for adaptations
of
fantasy stuff by these
these streaming services you know i'm
not going to i'm not interested in
watching the tolkien prequels either
about the second age
none of this stuff really looks that
well well set in the
narrative universes to me
i mean martin created in the books a
really interesting narrative universe i
think
game of thrones kind of so to speak
screwed the pooch when it comes to
um
seasons you know from six onward it was
just not very good so you know
all right uh
nishant
says
the only thing that affects my thinking
is
worrying how to translate into other
languages never notice any significant
thing
yeah
powell points out stoicism influenced
two at least two therapy approaches
donald robinson has actually pointed out
that it had an influence on early 19th
century french
psychotherapy as well that got kind of
lost
and submerged yeah
uh keaton says on the subject of music
do you have a favorite band mine is
animal collective are you familiar i
don't know animal collective um do i
have a favorite band if you'd asked me
like 30 years ago i would have said iron
maiden i don't really have a favorite
band now if i had to pick like
among metal bands by top ones it's not
surprising
iron maiden judas priest motorhead dio
rat
tank
uh black sabbath deep purple
you know those are rainbow rainbow in
the dio era metallica in the cliff
burton era including you know
willing to include injustice for all but
forget all the other stuff after that
you know um
those those are among my my favorites
um well the scorpions too i should put
in there as well
and except while they had udo um but
there are a lot of bands that i like
that are not metal bands as a matter of
fact this weekend we are going to be
seeing a band that may surprise many of
you that i have liked since
my pre-teen years
and that's duran duran
and we're like super looking forward to
that because we saw um on tv a concert
with them recently and they still they
still have it you know
we've seen some other bands recently
that
were pretty awesome
you know
sticks put on an amazing show
hauling oats you know that was a fun
show as well
i i'm also a big fan of new model army
never got to see them hopefully will
someday
um i mean who else do i really like you
know pj harvey
um
john cougar mellencamp but of course
he's he's you know long since gone
insane
so you know you can't really like see
the guy who who did uh
you know the classic stuff anymore i
would say
so there's a lot of author a lot of you
know bands that i i really do like
um i don't really have a favorite
any more than i have a favorite
philosopher you know
uh i do have a lot of other people
all right um
[Music]
let's see oop it just skipped a bit
again
um
j-crest do you have any advice for
reading something very dense like marx's
capital
these long-winded texts are very tough
to get through yeah i mean
dry stuff there right and i mean
take heidegger's being in time or you
know even starts being in nothingness is
kind of a head cracker isn't it
you just got to keep plowing through it
maybe you set yourself like a reading
schedule um
i mean i
the time when i was like early on
plowing through these texts i had the
luxury of being in graduate school
and
a lot of the times not even having a
teaching thing having a fellowship
instead so i had lots and lots of time
on my hands
most people i think don't really have
that that luxury so i don't know that i
have an awful lot of
helpful advice other than just keep
plowing away and maybe you know maybe
find some other people that are
interested in it that are not super like
argumentative or jockeying for a
position but like you can have good
conversations with because that makes it
fun and interesting you know
mgl has a football question is aaron
rodgers going to retire after this
season
i don't know you know
i mean i thought i kind of knew who the
guy was and then he came out with all of
his covid craziness
and you you realize you know that all we
really see are the facades of the
outside that are fairly carefully
managed
and i don't know i don't know what's
going on in his brain um i mean
he's gonna have to retire sooner or
later and the packers are sooner or
later gonna have to find a a successor
we've been super spoiled for
you know a couple decades now
having a
good but inconsistent quarterback and
brett favre
uh from you know the 90s onward and then
having uh aaron rodgers
who
was sort of like brett favre except
without the hokey dumbness and
interceptions constantly throwing
interceptions
uh and he was kind of held back you know
he could have been a re he could he was
a great he is a great team leader he
could have been a much greater team
leader if we had gotten rid of mccarthy
who's now down in dallas
years and years ago and let rogers have
a more participatory role in the
coaching but
what are you going to do right the past
is the past
last naj as a rare philosophy graduate
that hails from saudi arabia yeah that's
very cool how would you start a
philosophy department from scratch
in a country that has no philosophy
departments now that is a very
interesting question
so
i mean
the first thing i would say
is look for some native talent you know
so if it's pretty rare that people
are you know philosophy graduates in say
saudi arabia we'll use that as an
example
figure out who the ones are and see if
you can get them interested in
you know being a faculty member or being
somebody who would be a supporter or
something like that and the reason i say
that is you need to have
you need to have a face for your
students that isn't just a whole bunch
of hired guns coming in from outside
but some some people who you know can be
good role models for them and the other
problem is
the people that you get coming in from
the outside might not stick around so
you need some people who have a stake in
being
there
and then you'd start looking around for
who you can get to
come and you know if i was doing stuff
in the present day if i was like
creating a philosophy department
i would want to bring in some people who
would live and work in that place but i
would also design the program
so that it was partially online and you
know could bring in people from the
outside who
you know might teach
a class or
might you know be faculty members but
not living right there in saudi arabia
and who would be you know
zooming skyping google meets whatever
microsoft teams whatever platform you're
using would be
participating in that way and then i
would i would also like be
i mean if i could design something from
the ground up like that this is a
fascinating question
i would i would be thinking about like
okay who's going to be the
regional accreditor so that the degree
counts for something how am i going to
meet those
those standards
and how are we going to form connections
with other not just individuals but
organizations and departments all around
the world
to support what we're doing
in saudi arabia i'm sure you'd also have
some other
issues you know how do you make sure
that you don't get in trouble with
the religious establishment and the
political establishment
that might be something important as
well
so but that that is a really i mean
that's a great question um that's
something i'll probably be thinking
about the rest of the day and and i'm
willing to bet that my wife and i at
dinner
when we're doing that later on may be
talking about that because she is
somebody who helps like build programs
you know for for example the culinary
institute of america you know
um
so yeah that's that's a great question
uh the king any thoughts on the
situationist international or gita board
not really um i tend to think that the
society of the spectacle is uh
an interesting text but maybe
quite a bit dated and overrated um
let's see there's a good question here
for
we're just skipped um
mikhail says happy birthday i want to
ask what got you interested in
philosophy
so
i i would say that i i was always
interested in some of the things that
philosophy tends to focus on like
you know thinking about arguments you
know my mom when i was a kid said you
should be a lawyer because you love to
argue with people
and i mean that that could be a good
reason to be a lawyer but it could be a
good reason to be
a historian or a philosopher or a
rhetorician as well right
so that was part of it and i was always
you know interested in like bigger
picture questions like
you know what's real what's not you know
metaphysical questions like that what
are people is there a human nature you
know what makes people good or bad
um and then you know
i think you really get introduced to
philosophy in
elementary or middle school
i did take two
classes one of which was introduction to
philosophy it was terrible just awful
dry boring dull formulaic
and you know fortunately i took another
class that was supposed to be a
sacraments class a religious class right
and the guy who was brought in as the
substitute teacher taught us about
augustine and before that he taught us
about plato and aristotle and we did a
lot of philosophical discussion and so
that was kind of um helpful for
for me um that that probably played a
important role
uh rhino how many hours do you read a
day depends on the day um and and
depends on what we count as reading like
if you're asking reading actual books
some days i don't read any books some
days i spend half the day reading you
know
there's reading like for pleasure
there's reading for because i'm gonna
teach this this thing tomorrow
you know there's reading for getting
ready for a talk or working on an
article
you know so there's all different kinds
and then there's you know am i reading
philosophy am i reading literature am i
reading just you know blog posts or
things like that reading my my students
work these are all different kinds of
readings so i don't really have a
measure
like that uh casual says i was listening
to some duran duran yesterday reflex was
the number one song when i was born
uh funny when alan partridge called them
the thatcher pop four piece yeah i don't
know about that thatcher pop four piece
i guess because they were you know not
very politically
involved and they were you know kind of
a fun band maybe that was the the idea
ben what are your thoughts on rules for
radicals by saul olinsky
haven't read it so i don't have any any
views on it
um
bend of all thoughts on henry armand
giroud critical pedagogy haven't read
them so you know you're gonna find
there's a lot of people i haven't read
um
keaton says have you interacted much
with saint theresa lizzo i'm in rcia and
think i will take her as my confirmation
or maybe john of the cross nah i never
really read her much
so um
let's see
here we go
nishant patil any opinion on
thought-provoking
films
yeah i mean there's lots of films that
are good but but you know you find it in
a lot of cases
is there'll be like so much potential
and then it's not really
realized because they have to fall back
into the formulas of okay we resolve the
problem the hero wins or the love
interest or stuff like that
i kind of like the films where
things aren't
quite so um neatly
worked out and i think there's there's a
lot of them out there
and some of them could just be like
telling a story
that's quite interesting my favorite
film of all time is the duelists
which is a really early early ridley
scott film and it's about these guys who
are fighting with each other throughout
the napoleonic wars one's played by
keith carradine and the other one by
harvey atel and harvey keitel is the
belligerent jerk and
you know so there's a lot of things
about ethics that you could say that
kind of fit in there um and the meaning
of life and history and stuff like that
um
banger says bon anniversaire merci uh
keaton patrick jordan love is gonna set
the league on fire uh
i mean
you hope so jordan love is the second
string quarterback for our green bay
packers
he's kind of uneven i mean you hope for
the best right
all right uh hans um if i remember
correctly in one of your live streams
you mentioned marx was a very
aristotelian thinker could you explain
what you meant by that i think he's very
aristotelian i think he's he's you know
he's working within an aristotelian
framework i mean think about the way
that aristotle understands um
the role of political science in
relation to the rest of society and the
importance of
you know
material factors like
wealth and poverty for human development
and the need for some sort of
substantive political community in which
we can live a good life those are all
key aristotelian ideas and i see those
as uh kind of central to
marx's work i mean you could think of
aristotle as somebody who's like oh it
kind of sucks that you know
uh not everybody can live the good life
you know we gotta have slaves until we
until we have you know tools that can
handle uh you know like weaving on their
own and stuff like that and you could
think about marx in the 19th century as
saying
okay we've got those tools how do we
rearrange society
so that human beings can develop their
their you know genuine human nature and
not be just subjugated to a
process that sucks the life out of them
and throws them away i mean if aristotle
were around in the 19th century i think
he and marx would have a lot
in common with each other
planet c-64 i had to learn fast about
plato's republic and bam you opened up
my world thanks well i'm glad that
that's helpful i mean i don't have
videos on the entirety of plato's
republic unfortunately uh but you know
there's a good bit of stuff that's
covered book four books
book one
book seven and six and book ten i i
probably need to do some more on some of
the other ones
oh this is very cool rhino horn my old
phd classmate is looking to start the
first chinese philosophy program in
bangladesh you might say well why would
you start a chinese philosophy program
in bangladesh you know isn't that a
muslim country yeah but bangladesh is
you know
right over i mean
the only thing in between bangladesh and
china is depending on which way you're
going around the himalayas or the
you know southeast asian countries um i
think that's that's a great idea as a
matter of fact i think that
we probably should have a lot more um
teaching and study of chinese philosophy
here in in america than we do
unfortunately i'm not equipped to be an
expert on that i don't you know read
classical chinese but
that is really quite cool a lot of
birthday wishes from
bruno atari diamond josiah adam so
that's that's good
um
ben duvall what are your thoughts on
lukas gramsci thomas mann's novel the
magic mountain specifically the
character leonatha well i got to stop
you right there i've never read the
magic mountain so i don't have any
thoughts on that
uh hamza thoughts on cobblestone's
history of philosophy
so
i think cobblestone is pretty good still
uh today
and he's pretty reliable i mean there's
some places where you're like yeah i
don't know that he's got this completely
right but
he rarely leads you astray he's good at
not jumping onto bandwagons or you know
reductive approaches to things i was
just bringing him up the other day in
terms of hegelian thesis antithesis
synthesis which every everybody knows
hegel knows hegel didn't use right and
cobblestone has like a whole you know
two paragraphs or three paragraphs on
how all these other people
get this screwed up and and what's
actually going on in hegel's work so i
think he's i think he's pretty good
um
let's see ben duvall barack obama was a
student of saul lalinski yeah so what i
mean
uh we're not all like you know clones of
the people who we study with i mean how
many students of mine do you think are
out there doing exactly what i do so
it's kind of irrelevant
some more happy birthday wishes from
ashburn
uh zach nightshift stoic
uh cola moose
and uh k ghost and randall
um
[Music]
andromeda
any ideas how to be intellectually
engaged outside of a college environment
lots of ideas i mean that's part of what
i do right
you can do it by participating in
communities like this on youtube or
you can find local groups that are
interested in doing philosophy whether
it's a death cafe or socrates cafe or
stoic fellowship or sophia chapter
all those sorts of things and
you know
there's there's all sorts of
international communities that you can
participate in it's good to remember too
that a lot of the people that we study
in academic philosophy
they had lives outside of the academy
you know
descartes had a few offers to teach in
amsterdam but he did his own thing right
i mean he was a tutor to queen christina
of sweden but that didn't last long he
got a got sick and died um
but you know he's a prime example
um
even those who opened up schools like
epictetus
were very involved in their community
you know so
there's lots and lots of ways powell any
thoughts on phenomenology that's a vast
field
um yeah i mean i i like quite a few
phenomenologists i actually wrote my
master's thesis on husserl
um i routinely
teach heidegger and gabriel marcel and
um
i mean sart is kind of a phenomenologist
he's using some of the the resources so
i guess you could count him
in there sometimes teach mock shaler as
well so
um
oops just skipped again let's see what
we got going on
randall says are you tired of talking
about philip k dick because i want as
much information on his work as you can
give no i'm not i'm not i'm not tired of
uh philip k dick as a matter of fact as
you know his fans are called a big
[ __ ]
and um
i'm probably going to do you know more
videos on his his
various novels
and
um some of his other pieces
you know i'm actually having to move i
was going to do him for worlds of
speculative fiction but i'm moving the
one from this month which is jg balor to
next month and displacing dick to
next year but i'm you know one of the
things i'd love to do
one of the projects i've wanted to do
for a long time
is to like go through all of dick's work
and produce something like a glossary
of all of the
philosophical theological and
psychological terminology and concepts
that he's he's using
and
produced that as like a book you know i
think that would be a really fun
research project so
um
otari would you recommend any text about
the social background for religion a
more anthropological view of religion to
be clear
nothing comes to mind offhand
donald shelton is an avid fan of
speculative fiction which invented world
would be found to be the most
interesting as a vehicle for discussing
philosophical concepts
i mean
our scott backer comes to mind our scott
backer was a philosophy
graduate student
who
really only didn't finish his his phd
because he started bringing out the
first parts of the
second apocalypse seven book series
that uh has a lot of philosophical
content worked into it metaphysical
ethical you know
epistemological
um
it took me a long time to warm up to it
but neil stevenson's anathem
um
example i mean philip k dick obviously
has a lot of philosophical content built
into his his works
uh characters discuss it dostoevsky is
another example of somebody ursula k le
guin
um
[Music]
even roger zelazny i would say there's
there's quite a bit of interesting
philosophy
in there as
well um
all right
juancho how do you read plato's seventh
letter
specifically on the refusal of putting
thought in text form i i think that so
if you're not familiar with the plato's
seventh letter distinguishes between a
number of different ways in which we can
communicate and whether we can actually
communicate the reality that's that's
out there you know for example the forms
and i think it's paradoxical
um i think it can be an effective
piece to read and think about but of
course it's paradoxical because the
letter itself is communication about the
inability to communicate
um
zeitgeist do you plan on doing any other
giant projects when you finish the half
hour hegel series yeah i do the next
text that i want to apply the half hour
hegel methodology or this close reading
methodology which by the way i've
already applied to another text
epictetus and caridian right
is descartes meditations and i have a
really great copy that may be on the
bookshelf right behind me of descartes
meditations
that i was fortunate enough to to find
in a used bookstore
i want to say actually in portugal
um
when i was when i was there in 2001
so it's the you know press university de
france version
that has
um
the french
which is not the original by the way it
has the latin original that descartes
wrote in and then the french translation
of that
and so uh it's also got the objections
and replies which i may or may not do um
but i thought i would apply the same
sort of thing to
medi to the meditations obviously it
won't take as much time as
the phenomenology and then i was
thinking
you know maybe starts being in
nothingness um
i don't know i have to consider what i'd
be up for after that i mean i also have
to find new crowd funding for it as well
because these things take a lot of time
and work
um
ridicule says a random question do you
look at aristotle's mean state as a
range or single point on the spectrum
neither because aristotle's mean state
is not just about a spectrum
um there's all these you know right way
right time right you know right person
there's it's a lot more complicated than
just a
spectrum
um keaton
opinion on the societal philosophical
impacts of tick tock i don't really have
any
because i don't pay much attention to it
okay ghost what's a good way to start
with heidegger so i
start my students with what is
metaphysics and the advantage of that
for you if you're starting with
heidegger is that i already have a whole
series of videos on that essay what is
metaphysics and podcast episodes so that
might be uh a good place i i like it
because it it brings in a lot of the
key themes that are going to show up in
in other heidegger works
like anxiety or you know the history of
metaphysics or the nothing or all these
cool things
um
and it does so in one single article so
i think that's a good place to start
drewer uh thoughts reflections dreams on
carl young i think carl young is highly
overrated i i find when i read him when
he's talking about other people i find
that much more interesting than his own
system
i'm not big on jungians as well
keaton since you're a fan of
phenomenology have you read any edith
stein of red edit steinya
she was actually
the at the very first society thomas day
of studies in juvensie in
france
she was the invited guest to talk about
um connections between tomism and
phenomenology
um
toby house do you think you may go back
to hosting public speculative fiction
talks reviews i don't know what you mean
by go back i've been doing that
consistently right um
we just last month we did roger zelazny
so
i've been doing that for a long time
um
ben uh
let's see
ben says if you're curious oh this is
just
addressing somebody else about michael
su gray i i mean i knew about michael
sugrey years and years ago
um the early frankfurt school just has
not been that that influential anybody
who tells you that they are is full of
crap
it'd be great if they actually were more
influential but they haven't been
they've just been used as kind of a
whipping post for conservatives
uh nishant do you find schopenhauer a
depressing experience we read as a few
essays and boom world too bad
no because uh i don't i don't have to
buy into whoever i'm reading i'm not you
know
i'm not that influenced by by the
you know and i enjoy reading
schopenhauer he's a great writer i mean
the one thing i don't like about
schweppenhauer is his invidious
uh complaints about hegel but you just
overlook that you know you're like well
it's sort of like having a friend who's
got a few things wrong with them
and every once in a while they want to
talk crap about somebody and you're like
listen i'm not interested in that you
know
so
all right um
guy what is your opinion on the new dune
movie very promising we'll see if the
next installation
keeps it up right that's kind of
important
uh oh here we go bend of all professor
james lindsay's new discourses blah blah
blah lindsay is an idiot and anybody who
takes him seriously gonna say this as
well it's pretty stupid too
so i mean
this is a great come to jesus moment for
you i suppose you know um lindsay is so
nutty and such a hack
that he's not to be taken seriously
uh paul heinrich dietrich to what extent
can philosophy be considered as
independent of science in your view all
the way i mean every discipline is
pretty independent of other disciplines
science isn't a big capital s thing
there are the sciences
and they're all over the place right
there's no such thing as
science capital s anymore then there is
uh you know philosophy capital p that's
all the same thing
um
let's see here
keaton says i would be excited for the
half-hour descartes and sartre would
definitely contribute to the funds
that's good to know
um
and sam happy birthday are you familiar
with lambda
and i'm familiar with lambda but lambda
was uh uh some
i don't remember exactly like uh
or maybe i'm mixing it up with something
else uh
it had to do with like age of consent
and stuff like that so i don't i don't
know what that would be in terms of ai
sentience so that's kind of a no
a non-starter michael do you think
uh michael sugray explains philosophy
properly and clearly some of the time
and i wouldn't rely on him overly
uh he's you know like everybody else
he's got his own
peculiarities
his stuff is uh quite you know the stuff
that's out there on youtube is quite old
um
ksbf do you think sart is correct in
rejecting freud's
unconscious dualistic split of a psychic
unity in the self
instead arguing instead that what is
repressed is known to be the conscious
mind i think they're both wrong quite
frankly
on this sort of thing so you know
um
mia says happy birthday what do you
think about seneca's letter to lucillus
where he says you should not read too
widely well he's saying you shouldn't
read too widely because you should read
deeply and i kind of think that you know
it's up to us what we want to do there
is a danger of being very
superficial especially for reading
garbage you know things that pretend to
be
great you know takes on philosophy quite
often aren't
um you know a good example of this is um
that durant's the story of philosophy
which gets a lot of things wrong and and
gives people the
impression that they actually know what
they're talking about
um
so
it's very funny here there's like a big
fan club from for michael sugray um
i mean
it's weird that you would show up here
and then try to convince me that i
should read i should check out somebody
who i checked out you know over a decade
ago but you know
uh i guess you should form a fan club or
something ben felt and mark say happy
birthday csl happy birthday
drewer uh interesting one of the few
times you've resorted to name calling as
though as regards lindsay i resort to
name calling all the time
um
and uh i'm not going to take lindsay
seriously i mean i blocked him on
twitter with the stupid drivel that he
was saying and frankly i mean
i'm not gonna waste my time
uh with that if you want to follow
lindsay then you go this way and i go
this way and i know that the path i'm
taking is a good one and you can find
out where your path leads
um sophie kefford happy birthday i loved
your videos on cicero they were really
helpful as i was writing my dissertation
on that's awesome i'm glad to hear that
um
csl what is the difference between
essentialism and nominalism depends on
who you ask and whose isms you have in
mind
kbsf uh can you elaborate on why both
freud and start are wrong and their
premises of the unconscious i think
freud's theory is is you know there's
interesting bits to it but i think that
he's he's wrong in the way that he
construes things and i think that sartre
is wrong in saying that no it's all
consciousness and you've just like
hidden some of it from you you know
there there can be other ways to to work
on on that
uh ben thoughts on ideologies being a
new religion and psychoanalytic critical
theory the new superstition i'd say
that's a really dumb perspective to take
and i hope that you can work your way
out of that so that you can live a a you
know good intellectual life
you know um but if that's the sort of
nonsense that you're you're buying into
i just feel pity
uh mayhem happy birthday love your
content from iran and nice to have
people that may must be pretty late here
right
um kbsf asks about particular birthday
memory i i mentioned that earlier i do
have to get wrapping up pretty soon too
because i i have some other things i
have to do
andrew van orton happy birthday i'm glad
i finally caught a live stream i've been
meaning charles taylor right um i've
loved his books but i found out his book
on hegel isn't viewed positively
yeah taylor's an interesting guy
i've oh i'm not a big fan of his
i mean he makes claims
that you you seem a bit implausible like
interiority was discovered with
augustine
and you're like has the guy not read
much hellenistic philosophy i i don't
know about that you know
um
but he's you know he's he's important
[Music]
mahan is it fine for someone to start
philosophy by reading the republic so
that's a great question
you can start philosophy reading
anything you want right there's no
there's no one single you have to come
in this way or you have to come in this
way place
and the republic is not a bad place to
start i mean
it's it's a pretty long book and with
any text and philosophy
you're gonna you're gonna have an
initial read of it and you're gonna get
at best like maybe
one third of what's actually going on
maybe less than that i mean in my case
usually less than that
and you're gonna have to come back to it
after reading other texts and you're
gonna have to re-read
so i mean i don't think it's a bad place
to start if you're gonna talk about
platonic dialogues you could also start
with the apology
or with uh the shortest dialogue the ion
or you could start with the symposium or
you could start in all different places
right
uh rhino horn what's your opinion on
russell's history of western philosophy
well written poorly thought through i
wouldn't rely upon it
uh ben thoughts on ralph waldo emerson
and his essay self-reliance i don't have
any thoughts on that
uh kbsf uh happy birthday digging the
schopenhauer series yeah i've got a few
more lined up to come out uh ben felt
simple question where's the best place
to start when reading nietzsche and
heidegger so heidegger i mentioned
earlier i start people off on what is
metaphysics
nietzsche i mean where should you start
with him
i don't know it depends on what you're
into right if you like more systematic
works
genealogy of morals and uh
you know
the birth of tragedy are the places to
go if you're into like
more aphoristic all over the map kind of
stuff beyond good and evil is pretty
good
um
you could start with the spark thus
spoke zarathustra and that's actually
the first nietzsche book i read
but
i don't know you know i think some
people really like that and other people
not quite so much right
dr beavis suggests twilight of the idols
i mean there isn't like a best place to
start with nietzsche i think
um
i mean in my classes i typically
i'm having my students like in an
existentialism class they're reading
parts of the spokesarathustra
i also you know have a supplementary
reading on truth and lies in an extra
moral sense and then parts of the
genealogy you know
but i like the more systematic stuff you
know so
uh mahan asked about
friedrich cobleston's uh
uh history of philosophy just talked
about that a couple minutes ago
and uh
yeah so zeitgeist says i would say the
spoke zarathustra is harder to
understand if you're not familiar with
nietzsche's work yeah i mean
there's a lot of stuff in it where
you're like what what is this guy trying
to get at he seems really upset about
stuff i'm not quite sure
what's what's going on
so
all right well this is a good place to
wrap up i i need to uh
get ready for the rest of the day i
gotta work on my
marquette classes and uh because i'm
teaching for them in the fall
get a shower we're going to the the cat
cafe a little bit later on and then so
you'll see pictures of that on social
media and then um
having some you know uh dinner at the
calderon club tonight so that'll be fun
so thanks for everybody for for joining
me and uh
you know 52 uh hopefully i'll have a lot
more birthdays coming up those of you
who a few of you have birthdays today as
you mentioned earlier happy birthday to
you or you got birthdays coming up and i
will see all of you later on